missoula papa los angeles ، لذلك
أخشى المرتفعات وهذه دولة معرضة للزلازل
نحن في وسط مدينة لوس أنجلوس ، لذلك لست
متأكدًا تمامًا من سبب موافقي على القيام بذلك
ولكني ملتزمة بذلك
فهذه هي نهاية الأمر هنا  ما أتحدث عنه ،
ستلاحظ هذه الشريحة الصغيرة وهي
السماء تنزلق على قضيبك وتنبيه الانزلاق
في حوض من منزل متنقل في
ضواحي أكاديمية ليوبيرت وفيفا
أسفل شريحة تقليم في الواقع هو لا كافا
واكا الشاب الرائع أونا سيمانا  para esta
bien ahora de patatas كان عمري 18 عامًا ، Yoho بعض
جوشوا المريح في منزل حاضن سيرينا ، تأكد من أن
الماء دفع إريتريا قويًا أذهلني بعيدًا عن
حقبة mefs yo hablo ، صقل جلدي ،
هذا جنون على محمل الجد يمكنك
أن ترى في الأسفل رؤية واضحة تمامًا
تحقق من ذلك  في الخارج حتى فوق
مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر لقد أتيت ، لقد كان ذلك ممتعًا بالفعل ،
حسنًا ، الأمر يستحق ذلك ، إنه سريع ،
هذه هي الحياة المعلقة للهواء فوق لا